hey guys i'm ryan right hey guys i'm
lauren god that's right
rock back lauren on the channel she's
back we're gonna watch the trailer for
the remake of Annie shut the front door
yeah been a nanny twice you have yeah
dude then this is the perfect really
good very cool but I have not seen this
is this the one with that girl that was
in that movie good question and it stars
that actor in that one movie she was in
like beasts of the southern yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's her
and has Jamie Foxx - oh right
I don't know now let's watch watch this
trailer by the way I'm already running
late for work I was like words here I'm
going to watch a trailer Annie
2014 she's pretty hot these are the
songs that does not happen in the movies
is really gonna help you race for mayor
oh she's so good
the more were seen together the better
it is for my campaign
if you're not really thinking about
doing this there's like so much fun
because it never lasts and from then on
out I'd love to be a black girl that you
can Christ max it's a miracle it's about
to get dramatic
you never know oh yeah they're buggy
what tomorrow will bring what you're
looking for right in front of your face
it's her why would you clean the inside
of the window she's with me oh yeah
oh well that movie looked fun I want to
see it no well you're a nanny family
knowledgeable about musical theater and
they changed a lot of things to make it
modern bastard which is understandable
but I'm kind of a traditionalist and a
little peeved peeved yeah yeah strong
okay describe my emotion okay yeah I
mean to me it looks like it it would be
a good Christmas movie right the air
boards do go see this movie if you're
bored go watch the movie is that what
you said no it's what you do on
Christmas that's why you go see you
moving on Christmas because you're bored
here's just to spend time with your
family see really well let's go sit in a
dark movie theater where we don't have
to talk to each other ah a family woman
Lauren is you guys know what I'm talking
about you know what though Cameron Diaz
doesn't look too believable to me right
I can believe her performance as in his
Hanigan because I think that she can
achieve that crazy hag character but she
looks too hot yeah man
love to do stuff with her okay wouldn't
you we're done stuff with a girl you
haven't Wow a girl kissed me in college
it was really stupid it wasn't my
friends and she liked this guy we're at
partying and he was like you should kiss
her and she did did you guys make out no
she gave me a pack and I was like way to
give into this dude well dude you should
have given in and you should have
recorded it so we could react to that
instead I'm gonna go think about that
tonight what did the girl look like
she's very pretty she is okay well then
that's all that really counts Lauren as
a lesbian that would be awesome
no I were a lesbian then I wouldn't like
guys yes that's true but you liking guys
is not currently working in my favor
so I'd rather to get turned on my erotic
images from Lauren if you're new to the
channel thanks for recommending that by
the way for new to the channel subscribe
Lauren can sing you I was singing to the
anti trailer did you not hear me
I did hear you I was captivated by you
though hi Oh Warren what I just
mentioned this button do you know what
comes after that shoutouts all right all
right oh we're gonna be this time oh my
god you actually downloaded in my resume
he downloaded my rest I downloaded her
resume I want to know everything about
her CTG studio 421 yes sorry
he said he'll eat my
nipples off if I don't give him a
shout-out I like my nipples my nipples
are probably the best feature about me
speaking of nipples Lauren show us your
nipples yeah it's the best feature it's
the best feelings
everyone likes nipples I'm sure you have
wonderful nipples Lauren you showed them
your nipples oh dude I have plenty of
videos where you can see my nipples sure
i zoom in yeah and you can see my ass in
one video two nipples plus my ass yeah
don't act disappointed she was turned on
she went to the bathroom for a good few
minutes after that to vomit no that's
not what I heard you doing I listen
Brandon Arriaga oh my god he begged for
a shadow he literally was like he was
begging like whining well yeah so stop
whining Brandon come on you're just
shoutout
take it now go to the back of a whine
kidding buddy thanks for your support
Adam yeah Laurens a [ __ ] just a little
bit according to her I think she's a
sweet adorable little pumpkin I hide it
well she hides it well yeah but you
would be surprised this girl can kick
some lethal ass yeah I started learning
double daggers yesterday yup she keeps
talking about this I'm really into it
that's good that's good what else are
you in not one but two daggers oh yeah
do you like having more than one thing
no don't want to go there I'm scared of
you I'm gonna return that I didn't hear
that well if you ever want a threesome
with another guy you know who to call
yeah tell your accountant boyfriend
giulio nation's 72 are you Jewish it's
spelled
J e W ah you might be Jewish Jewish
people are cool man are you a Leo are
you part of this nation
Leo's yeah were you born in 1972 or
there are 72 of them in this nation ah
oh yeah more there's multiples of them
in this nation in year to 72nd member he
said that this what a shout-out would
make his day
week and year Wow happy 2014
yeah do nation you have high aspirations
if this is what will make your year for
you buddy I just insulted one in my jams
in yourself I did yeah
didn't look at it that way
self-deprecating can't get enough of it
thanks for watching
giulio nation 72 we really appreciate it
I once hooked up with a Jewish girl I
don't care it was cool because I grew up
Catholic so she was like really exotic
to me she didn't believe in Christ
that's exotic yeah